the folks you see in this picture are
two nasa astronauts who also happen to
be identical twins on the left here this
is mark kelly you can see his name on
his patch right over there and then this
is scott kelly and the reason why we
want to look at these two astronauts in
particular is to think about genotype
and phenotype that we have been
introduced to in other videos so just as
a bit of a review when people talk about
genotype they're talking about the
actual genetic information encoded in an
organism's genes so if you go inside a
cell we have chromosomes
and then on those chromosomes they're
long each chromosome is a long stretch
of dna
and then sections of that long stretch
of dna will code for various things
often usually various proteins
but there's a difference between what is
actually what information is in one's
genes versus what actually gets
expressed the observable characteristics
that is phenotype
and two people with the same genotype
they might have a very similar phenotype
but they won't necessarily have an
identical phenotype because of above and
beyond the genes affecting phenotype you
also have the environment
affecting
someone's phenotype so as you can see
here
mark and scott kelly they're identical
twins they have the same genotype but if
you just look at their facial
characteristics you can see that you
could tell the difference between the
two and it's not just the fact that mark
has a mustache and that scott doesn't we
could draw in a mustache you would still
see that they look different and that's
because their bodies developed in
different ways based on the environment
that they happen to be in and this idea
that the same genotype could result in
variations of phenotype this is known as
phenotype plasticity
phenotype
plasticity
and maybe in one of the most extreme
experiments ever conducted on phenotype
plasticity nasa was intrigued to see
well what would happen to the gene
expression if they if scott kelly spent
an extensive period of time in space
while his twin brother didn't so they
looked at how their bodies expressed
certain characteristics before scott
spent an extended period of time in
space and then after he spent that time
in space they studied his body and they
saw that there was differences in the
mitochondria differences in which genes
were expressed in fact there was a seven
percent difference in the gene
expression after the extended time in
space for scott so that's an example of
that space environment changing scott's
phenotype and the nasa scientists
theorized that it was a low oxygen
environment there was a lot of carbon
dioxide in that environment there were
stressors from space travel that would
have affected how the genotype which is
identical to his brother mark's genotype
how it might have been expressed
resulting in the phenotype plasticity
above and beyond what other changes in
phenotype between scott and mark
accumulated over the course of their
lives despite having the same genetic
information